welcome to this video I'm playing Nick
otic from Germany let's see as you have
a name in there Valerie bronze naked
it's a well-known author of chess books
so written quite a few books ok I'm
playing a form just get something
different I played two somewhat and I
come an opening so far from my games the
last two ones and I scored to win so I'm
tried you to stay on this track just
trying to play something different
okay that's a nice position out of the
Sicilian Russell emo um the question is
should i take and then f4 maybe hmm for
then probably f5 is coming taking on g6
very very dry not the same if i take f4
f5 maybe Queenie Titus's maybe still
something I can try to play for f5 is
coming I mean from black I think he will
probably play at five no we won't
surprising okay I get in f5 myself maybe
I will just wanted to complete
development first i covered you for that
there's not not some nasty check coming
just stabilize this position and then f5
yeah okay does not want to take it seems
okay threatening bishop age six here
the idea is night f form and then maybe
night to g6 even if possible okay looks
like a good structure white so should I
take with the Queen knoweth the pond I
take with the pawn I have this
opportunity rook foh for maybe do that
it's a not bad from structural point of
view anyway okay I got the bishop to e5
yeah that's true here rookie form key
one he can play Bishop before but I'm
quicker on the e-file just a slight
annoying advantage at least that's what
I hope and what I think at the moment
not have played quickly at least not
being hopelessly behind it's about even
on the clock yeah I'm not sure if I want
to exchange really at the moment with
this queen being in the in the e-file
maybe I can maybe build up a little bit
more before before I exchange exchange
stuff should g3 to open up to open up
maybe I'm definitely quicker on the far
now
yeah that's that's better for white but
it's not easy at all to to somehow
transform to a position where you can
can can find a direct winning i do
anything okay it's giving me giving me
the square g6 is it an idea maybe Queen
Queen g4s always rooted for putting the
Queen on g6 is this an idea maybe maybe
I should have done that maybe I should
have done that immediately but okay I
can do this first prepare it a bit not
really I can I can go here though come
off cover first and threatening rookie
seven here I know I can go to g6 I think
now this this this will become tricky
here ruki aid now is a substantial
threat h6 was a maybe I don't know this
looked very questionable to me
not giving me the g six square for I
don't know no particular reason okay so
it's this winning or not taking here and
then f6 it's very close for sure okay
it's got a 24 check maybe I need to
prevent this first check I can do this
this first and then just start to take
material yeah I have six of the strong
fear this i had seen before hand only
not sure if it's winning it should
really Queen takes I take on g7 here now
now I can take check here first and
check and again here let's see
what's the easiest way to win here I
shouldn't overlook wintec g2 I really
shouldn't it's an easy easy way to to
spoil it even but right now is in the
pin so i could just take yet another
pawn okay I thought I can just advance
that really to age 60 k time warning I
can take here and then I still get i get
b six years check so that's enough check
it's not maybe not the cleanest
technical play but it's enough check
check
the weaknesses and the King cut off
shouldn't be too much really check check
black resigns yeah this was somewhat
strange i mean i think that what right
is of course better here with the e
failure if anyone's better it's why
dance quite this is very nice to play
but h6 page six looks very forthcoming
maybe queen g6 immediately was stronger
even it's possible so that's it looks
very strong actually with the direct
threat and if he takes this is getting
very ugly upon the ads that's winning
that's a winning position forward it's
too much it's too too dominating he
never gets out of his box IAM and down
the Kings side but ok i wanted to to
keep more and more stuff on the board
and it looks it looks very very
dominating and roop these six this
should be clean clean win check check
yeah here there's certainly his may be a
major queen f3 is strong okay i pointed
out by the comp this this will win the
Queen actually okay but when is a win
i'm pretty sure that what I did was was
okay here i thought it was much easier
for him to to to play instead of
allowing me to play a fight which is not
fatal or anything and not saying that
but it seemed far better to me to play a
five
which also blocks my bishop in and i am
not sure maybe equal maybe yeah Black
has two bishops but they're not doing
that much at the moment gee I don't know
equal maybe roughly equal okay thanks
for watching